on va on va vous donner un micro
alors l'idée c'est que vous donniez en
fait votre appréhension comment ça s'est
passé comment vous avez vécu ça vaut un
confort vous qu'on fasse d'eux comme
vous l'êtes bas le plus gros à confort
c'est là ça me gêne un peu désolé pour
les gros mots assez que ça faut que ça
sorte un petit peu comme ça déjà j'ai
faim j'ai en fait j'ai jamais rien gagné
on est dans ma vie
enfin j'ai jamais la moindre tombola de
une à deux campagnes n'importe quoi avec
son panier garni avec c'est pas une
bouteille de pinard des chips à la
crevette ou du pâté hénaff j'ai jamais
rien gagné de ce genre tu ouvres la
propulser soiron rouge devant le
l'intelligentsia costarmoricaine même au
delà y en a qui viennent de brest qui
était en jambes et j'ai peur quoi les
voilages et j'avoue j'ai peur bon ça
voilà comme vous pouvez le voir je suis
vraiment un mauvais comédien donc on va
arrêter la mascarade rentrer dans le jeu
de l'honnêteté entre nous oui je lave ou
mon intervention était prévu et au nom
de toute l'équipe de tedx nous l'avouer
nous sommes deux joyeux farfelues qui
vous avons préparé cette surprise du
coup bah je veux bien micro comme les
autres histoire de me libérer les voies
là continuez continuez à c'est bon vous
m'entendez oui avec arrête je veux bien
un petit coup de maquillage si je viens
peut dire julien le nigeria mais bon
voilà
bon maintenant je suis en bonne
disposition en plus certains d'entre
vous qui me connaissent se sont dits oui
ça paraît un petit peu bizarre de
retrouver là devant nous maintenant
c'est pas le fruit du hasard bien que
mon nom de super héros soit gaspard
hazard et ceux qui me connaissent pas et
qui ont bien étudié le provost le
programme avant de venir se sont dit
mais bon quand un artiste là on a quand
même payer 20 balles tout ça c'est bon
on va pas nous la faire à nouveau vibrer
la petite dame être dans l'élite ça
coûte cher
regardez par exemple le prix des billets
de chevalier à laspalès j'ai regardé la
45 euros ils sont que deux sur scène
à rennes la liberté c'est la semaine
prochaine mais c'est complet aussi
étonnant que cela puisse paraître
au passage je voulais remercier ouest
france pour avoir joué le jeu en tentant
de brouiller les pistes en annonçant
dans la liste des artistes intervenants
ici ce soir un certain gérard verdure
alors ça m'a fait marrer en imaginant la
femme de gérard en ouvrant l'ouest
france l'autre joue en dix ans bah alors
tu m'avais khachik tête allait faire une
conférence et tout ça enfin bref
maintenant que je vous ai mis dans la
confidence
qu'est ce que je vais bien pouvoir vous
raconter je suis pas là pour donner une
conférence ses bons amis haute dose
bah déjà pour commencer je peux vous
parler un petit peu de moi comme je
disais précédemment
mon nom de super héros segas par hasard
mon nom civil c'est gaspard verdure j'ai
32 ans je suis née à strasbourg
je suis assez oublieux je suis arrivé à
saint brieuc il ya 17 ans maintenant et
dans la vraie vie je suis crieur public
et poète quand je dis que je suis un
super héros c'est ni plus ni moins comme
toutes les personnes qui m'ont précédé
sur cette scène bien sûr on les a vus la
posture forte et brillante le regard qui
transperce l'horizon la démarche
vaillante et le poil soyeux du vison
mais ce qu'on ne montre pas ce qu'on ne
montre pas c'est tous ces moments passés
à chialer notre mère en cachette et se
tordre la cervelle parce qu'on sait pas
comment on va s'en sortir pour ne pas
casser la se casser la gueule ce fameux
jour du discours soit disant le plus
important de notre vie à l'américaine
le super héros est avant tout quelqu'un
de super sensible qui aime le monde qui
peut pas se retenir de pleurer quand il
voit qu'elle sort on lui fait subir
là ça va j'ai fini ce matin et qui ne
peut pas rester longtemps à l'observer
sans vouloir le changer attention je dis
bien changé et non sauver le monde c'est
important pour moi cette nuance m'a
permis d'agir
l'idée de sauver le monde mettant
paralysante de toute façon le monde
change en permanence alors être autant
être dans le mouvement
et moi j'aime l'idée de changer un petit
peu le monde ou au moins mon quartier où
au moins ma colocation asparagine en y
semant un petit peu de poésie pas
forcément des poèmes pour moi la poésie
est bien plus large que ça je suis
convaincu qu'on peut trouver de la
poésie par exemple en allant chercher du
pain je me suis promis un jour d'écrire
un roman qui fera à peu près 1000 pages
ou de l'histoire c'est juste que je vais
chercher le pain est peut-être le retour
ou saas râle pour le tome 2 je sais pas
encore je crois pas être loin d'une
certaine vérité en affirmant que le
monde entier se cache dans la poésie ou
les trucs dégueulasses et tout super
l'amour la guerre tous pour moi mais je
ne suis pas sûr donc on continue à
écrire après quelle est la légitimité
d'un crieur poète à se retrouver dans un
tedx j'en sais rien peut-être qu'on peut
trouver un début de réponse en
s'imaginant un monde sans poésie comme
on peut s'imaginer un monde sans soleil
normand comme on peut s'imaginer un
monde sans clotilde de brito sans
musique sans poésie sans ou alors sans
photos de flore intestinale de poulet
vous imaginez un monde sans sens à un
gilles salvat quand même ça m'a
bouleversé cette histoire de poulet
l'afdi serait quand même bien plus fade
sans poésie ni bactéries c'est rigolo
aujourd'hui ici sur cette scène là j'ai
appris des choses en fera pas sur cette
scène mais dans le public j'ai appris
plein de choses j'ai parce que j'en
retiendrai mais je sens qu'à l'instar de
patrice hénaff l'ouverture de mon
manteau noir s'élargit et donne encore
plus de sens à crier dedans
oui les mondes entonnoir d'ailleurs ça
je vais prendre ça parce que du coup à
plat et oui ça c'est marqué ce même
fauteuil que tout à l'heure et voilà
alors voilà et du coup je dis souvent un
truc quand je vais sur le marché
voilà ça c'est un petit truc que je crie
sur le marché quand je vais faire les
criées public voilà bref je bafouille
alors au début oui au début quand j'ai
rencontré l'équipe tedx la première fois
la première fois je me suis pas
forcément senti super à l'aise
en fait j'ai cru me retrouver dans une
réunion parmi laquelle se trouvaient des
gens de droite avec des chemises des
polos des chaussures bien cirées des
pantalons repasser ça parlait
entrepreneuriat et business plan et avec
des anglicismes à tout-va gt ça me
change eh ouais en fait c'était c'était
flippant mais en même temps j'étais ému
c'était la première fois que
j'approchais des gens de droite d'aussi
près que j'ai même serré la main j'ai
touché en fait il avait une peau comme
les autres enfin en tout cas comme comme
mes potes artistes de gauche forcément
avec lesquels on passe le temps en
résidence au bistrot enfin ateliers
d'éducation populaire 1
donc on refait le monde avec nos utopies
nos idées révolutionnaires ou la bière
serait au prix populaire dans l'hérault
50 maximum est là
on voit la bande de gauchistes
d'ailleurs ce n'est qu'à la fin de la
troisième réunion que quelques bières
ont été proposés ce qui a commencé à me
faire douter le plus grand choc s'est
produit quand j'ai croisé deux de mes
camarades de partenaires d'organisation
lors du festival art rock quand
légèrement éméché je m'avance
joyeusement vers eux pour leur annoncer
que c'était mes premiers copains de
droite et qu'ils étaient quand même
sympa alors sérieuse les a fait un petit
peu sourire et on s'est assis pour
discuter tedx marcha sur les marches du
parvis de la passerelle juste devant
quant à la fin de la conversation celui
que je pensais le plus de droite de par
son look et son langage précieux avait
dix discrètement déracinés a pavé du sol
pendant qu'on discutait et sur un petit
bout de pâti la veille il avait écrit as
par la victoria siempre petit papier
qu'il posa dans le trou par lequel il
remit le pavé et ben là je vais merde
des gauchistes propre sur eux du coup je
lance un appel
je lance un appel pour rencontrer de
potentiels copains de droite 6 en 1 par
ici avec lequel on pourrait
éventuellement partager les barbecues
coopératif numérique n'est ce pas michel
briand je sais pas si les gens de droite
sont acceptés dans les projets sinon la
première chose la première chose qui
m'est venue à l'esprit quand on m'a
proposé de conclure ce tedx au petit
théâtre de la passerelle est magnifique
théâtre à l'italienne
première chose qui m'est venue c'est la
grenouille the frog
oui la grenouille la rana en italien vu
qu'on est dans un théâtre à l'italienne
je me suis dit que c'était là l'occasion
la 2 de réaliser un rêve c'est peut-être
la première et la dernière fois que j'ai
l'occasion de de faire la grenouille en
public dans un lieu aussi près
tige yeux mon rêve vous pouvez enfin
devenir réalité et en plus c'est mon
espace je fais ce que je veux ici c'est
maintenant c'est moi c'est moi qui suis
là au milieu de ce rôle voilà s'il
fallait pas l'inviter si vous vouliez
pas que je fasse la grenouille par
contre je vais vous demander
ah oui non c'est ça que j'ai dit
également et au diable les normes qui ne
veulent pas de batraciens dans les
théâtres et même si cette norme n'existe
pas on la vente pour la faire voler en
éclats à l'origine je compte sur toi
pour m'aider allez hop une grenouille
vite fait bien fait en fait pour faire
la grenouille avant je vais avoir besoin
de vous parce qu'il faut quand même une
mise en condition faut que j'ai
l'impression d'être au bord d'un étang
et tout ça est en fait je vais vous
demander à vous de faire la grenouille
attention à n'y allez pas tout de suite
s'il vous plaît je vais vous demander de
faire une grenouille particulière alors
certains d'entre vous connaissent
peut-être je vous demander de faire la
grenouille de steve waring il a déjà vu
ce spectacle c'est la première fois que
je le fais j'ai fini le truc ce matin je
viens d'avoir l'idée là dans les dans
les fauteuils tout à l'heure donc on va
partager la la salle enfin ce petit
théâtre en quatre comme ça la pac
enfin 1 2 en bas 3 4 1 2 3 4 coupes au
milieu si vous êtes au milieu vous
choisissez vous aller soit à gauche soit
à droite fonctionne
alors on va commencer par en bas à
gauche forcément vous allez me faire une
petite grenouille qui fait oui tu vois
tu
ouais tu vois tu ouais tu vois tu bois
tu vois tu continuais comme ça a
continué ouais tu vois tu en bas à
droite vous allez me faire suis ici suis
ici suis ici suis ici suis ici suis ici
suis ici suis estime continuer en haut à
gauche
vous allez faire la troisième grenouille
qui fait aussi chaud ça use ça use ça
use ça use ça use ça use ça allait on
continue parce que la 4e grenouille haut
à droite
vous allez faire dans la boue dans la
boue dans la boue dans la boue dans la
boue dans la boue dans la boue un laisse
continuer plus fort je vous entends pas
même s'il ya le truc qui cependant
machin continuer vite
merci
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué la
petite subtilité la couleur la couleur
vert pour ac arles et la grenouille
merci à vous donc voilà la grenouille à
la passerelle ça c'est fait je peux
mourir maintenant enfin je vous rassure
je vais mourir après parce que j'ai
quand même pas bosser pour venir gérer
ses cheveux voilà en fait je voulais
dire aussi à l'instar d'erik marchand
tout qui rendait toute à leur hommage à
son maître
manuel kerjean alors qu'il a mené petit
à petit a expliqué que non harmonique
jeu n'a pas le monopole de la musique
le mode allociné magistral gros à
l'instar de cet anti star qu'est avec
marchands en faisant la grenouille sur
scène c'était aussi une manière pour moi
de rendre hommage aux crieurs de rue de
rua à rennes qui m'a fait découvrir le
métier de crieur public et cet [ __ ]
il m'a aussi appris à faire la
grenouille c'est crevant le merci groben
quand même fou au passage philippe
carrese si jamais tu as besoin d'un
homme grenouille pour aller chatouiller
le coelacanthe tu sais que tu peux
compter sur moi
souvent à la clarté rouge des réverbères
dont le vent bas la flamme et tourmente
le vert au coeur d'un vieux faubourg
labyrinthe franc jeu où l'humanité
grouille en fermant aura je vois un
chiffonnier qui vient au chant la tête
butant et se cognant comme un poète et
sans prendre souci des mouchards ces
sujets et penche tout son coeur en
glorieux projet ils prêtent des serments
dicte des lois sublime terrasses les
méchants relève les victimes et sous le
firmament comme un des suspendus sont
ivres des splendeurs de sa propre vertu
charles baudelaire le vin des
chiffonniers extraits est ce que pascal
souhaitera vous êtes toujours par ici
ouais ok est ce que vous avez toujours
votre talon le petit talon de tout à
l'heure est ce que c'est possible de me
le prêter ou enfin ou levante vous le
donner éventuellement le troc
qu'est ce que je peux j'en ai un autre
merci merci
vous pourrez continuer à parler à vous
pouvez refaire la grenade si vous voulez
vous souvenez des paroles donc voilà à
peu près de dix minutes je crois dix
minutes que quand je parle pour ne rien
dire
mais après tout la poésie n'est ce pas
ça brasser du vent pour avoir de l'air
merci